bien l'écouter bienvenue à aux
républicains valérie de bord et moi-même
philippe juvin nous sommes heureux de
reprendre cette habitude des conférences
de presse hebdomadaires donc désormais
nous aurons le plaisir de nous revoir
tous les lundis nous au sens large parce
que comme nous sommes plusieurs porte
parole nous relaierons sur les sujets
d'actualité pour commenter l'actualité
qui vient de se dérouler celle qui
pourrait se dérouler évidemment répondre
à vos questions
donc le premier sujet aujourd'hui c'est
évidemment la conférence de presse du
président de la république hier soir
avec un certain nombre de sujets qui ont
été abordés
je vais passer la parole à valérie sur
sur un certain nombre d'entre eux ce qui
nous a frappés c'est qu'on a eu d'abord
une première phase d'auto justification
il a beaucoup parlé de lui même
on a ensuite eu l'impression que tout ça
pour ça beaucoup d'imprécisions sur des
sujets importants parlera des
universités beaucoup de sujets non
traités et pas des moindres les
questions européennes ont été traités en
une phrase il nous a annoncé qu'il
tenait beaucoup à l'europe c'est tout ce
qu'il a dit sur europe est arrivé une
minute avant la fin sur ce sujet donc
rien sur les questions absolument
stratégique des relations commerciales
avec les pays qui aujourd'hui nous
menace v localisation je pense à la
chine absolu rien sur le président quand
on sait que ça va avoir des effets
majeurs sur l'économie française et
particulièrement sur l'agriculture je
vous rappelle que le bric site
c'est 3 milliards de moins pour la pac
le départ des anglais ils payent
actuellement 3 milliards à la pac
politique agricole commune à 7,3
milliards vont disparaître aucun aucune
réflexion là-dessus aucune réflexion sur
l'immigration vu dans ses aspects
européens
aucune remarque sur la question des
travailleurs détachés j'y reviens je
reviendrai donc on a eu l'impression
d'avoir parfois non pas un président de
la république mais un sous-secrétaire
d'état des questions très techniques qui
par le petit bout de la lorgnette abordé
un certain nombre de sujets aussi de
façon très confuse donc à l'airé sûr
certains nombre de ses points merci
merci philippe bonjour à toutes et à
tous peut-être en préambule il faut
reconnaître un maquereau quelque chose
il a réussi à sortir le parti socialiste
de son ambivalence pluri décennale entre
le collectivisme et la social démocratie
est en fait la gauche française est
enfin rentré dans ce que l'ensemble des
gauches européennes ont depuis plusieurs
dizaines d'années c'est à dire qu'en
fait elle est devenue social démocrate
il faut s'en réjouir puisque une sortie
ressorti des vielles lunes contre
lesquels plus personne dans le monde
n'ose est réellement lutter cette
social-démocratie elle existe un petit
peu partout effectivement en europe
elle a des éléments sur lesquels nous
pouvons être en accord on voit que
autour des dispositifs sur la loi de
travail il y à un certain nombre de
mesures qui nous satisfait on aurait
même aimé que ça y'a un petit peu plus
loin mais il faut clairement l'indiqué
nous sommes sur cette ligne sur une
ligne qui peut rejoindre ces éléments
sur la façon dont le président de la
république a souhaité mener son
interview hier
nous regrettons dans un premier temps
qu'ils aient oublié beaucoup de gens
c'est vrai qu'il me l'alma kron c'est la
france des gens qui vont bien qu'ils
créent des start up qui vont à
l'international qui font des discours
pour expliquer que le monde est en train
d'évoluer ce qui est vrai mais cette
france-là cette europe là elle est aussi
constituée de dizaines de millions de
gens qui ne vont pas bien la france
périphérique comme on dit chez les gens
intelligents la france périurbaines
cette france qui n'a pas accès au très
haut débit et non pas aux débits simple
cette france qui a du mal à joindre les
deux bouts
cette france qui est un peu perdu dans
ce monde numérisé globalisé étonnamment
on n'en parle pas les agriculteurs
philippe effectivement a évoqué la pac
et ça c'est extrêmement important
toutes les personnes qui se sentent des
qualifiés méconnu non reconnus qui
professionnellement n'avance pas
n'évolue pas eh bien quelle ambition
ce gouvernement dresse aujourd'hui pour
permettre à tous les français
eh bien
d'arriver sur un rêve commun et ça il
nous semble que au delà des mots c'est
quelque chose qui cruellement manque
après il ya un domaine qui a été un peu
disons imprécis dans les mots d'un
président qui pourtant est techniquement
si précis c'est tout ce qui tourne
autour de ce choc fiscal majeur qui est
l'augmentation de la seiche pascal
almagro on parle de 1 7% d'augmentation
leur évidence une façon de minimiser les
choses mais la réalité c'est une
augmentation de fiscalité de 25% pour
les retraités à partir de 1200 euros
brut par mois 1200 euros brut par mois
et là on est clairement dans la volonté
complètement contraire à celle du
président de la république qui a fait du
travail l'alpha et l'oméga de son
discours et qui nous explique que le
fruit du travail de toute une vie
puisque prélévé la csg supplémentaires
sur une retraite sur une pension c'est
toucher au fruit du travail de toute une
vie
et bien ce fruit du travail de toute une
ville n'est pas reconnue et c'est
complètement contradictoire avec
l'intégralité d'un discours ça c'est une
première chose qui nous fera beaucoup
la deuxième chose c'est effectivement
l'imprécision de la compensation nous
parle effectivement d'une taxe
d'habitation qui reviendrait pour un
certain nombre de personnes à partir de
mais si on regarde la réalité des
chiffres
on voit très bien que on nous explique
que c'est vrai pour un retraité quid des
couples vous savez que la moyenne
la taxe d'habitation en france elle est
autour de 700 euros on nous promet de
revenir sur un tiers de cette somme
quand vous êtes un clip un couple pardon
on va vous prélevez deux fois votre csg
on va pas vous redonner deux fois la
taxe d'habitation
donc là il y à un loup d'imprécisions
dont on voit très bien que le président
de la brique ne souhaite pas en sortir
on sort toujours de la précision à son
détriment
c'est en la matière quelque chose qui
nous a frappés et qu'ils méritent non
pas d'être dénoncés dans une forme de
rhétorique partisane mais qui mérite
tout simplement d'être dit
on ne peut pas se présenter comme le
président de tous les français
et de façon complètement mécanique
oublier que on va pour 90% des français
à partir du 1er janvier
et bien leur faire baisser leurs revenus
90% des personnes qui vont avoir leurs
cg augmenté vont voir leurs revenus
leurs revenus baisser si on veut se
présenter comme un président du travail
c'est effectivement un petit peu mal
parti donc sur les questions économiques
a eu effectivement cette question du
choc fiscal qui va être considérable
qu'on a probablement aujourd'hui dans
les commentateurs politiques sous-estimé
c'est pour ça que nous attirons votre
attention là dessus ça va être un choc
fiscal majeur en particulier pour les
retraités puis un deuxième sujet qu'il
n'a fait que survoler et qui pourtant
pourrait avoir un effet comment
dirais-je à la fois économique mais
quasiment psychologique majeur de même
ampleur que celui des 35 heures c'est la
question de la réforme de l'assurance
chômage l'assurance chômage aujourd'hui
c'est un déficit tous les angles 3,6
milliards d'euros
et c'est à une date cumulé 33 milliards
d'euros
est ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
aujourd'hui quand on est un cdi et que
le cdh il prend fin et bien dans 56% des
cas là la fin du cdi est liée à une
démission
56% des cas et que dans 17 % sont des
ruptures conventionnelles
le risque donc de ce que veut faire
emmanuel macron à savoir d'ouvrir
l'assurance chômage à la totalité des
fans cdi et majeur parce qu'il risque de
créer un effet d'aubaine
l'effet d'aubaine vous l'avez compris
avec environ 75% des fans cdi qui sont
des fins de cdi volontaire c'est de
créer cet effet d'aubaine qui ruinerait
carrément le système d'assurance chômage
et qui créerait surtout une relation au
travail et à l'employeur entre le
salarié et l'employeur totalement
asymétrique avec au fond la possibilité
pour celui qui met fin au cdi de n'avoir
pas de conséquences et d'être dans une
sorte de situation de au fond de guichet
ouvert
est ce qu'on a connu avec les 35 heures
qui ont été dévastateurs pour
l'industrie et l'économie française
par la simple fait du simple fait de
diminution de ton travail mais plus
encore pour des raisons psychologiques
en gros celui qui travaille c'est celui
qui se fait avoir avec les 35 heures
c'est ça que signifiait et c'est ça
aujourd'hui qui est un des vrais sujets
de la société française et bien au
risque de la voir puissance 10 avec
cette réforme totalement totalement
incroyable de l'assurance chômage
vous savez le diable réside vraiment
dans les détails et là on n'est plus
dans le détail 75 % des fins de cdi sont
sur la base volontaire d'une certaine
manière et si vous faites ça et si à ces
gens là vous dites et bien vous ouvrez
l'assurance-chômage libre sans aucun
filet de sécurité vous ruiner le système
et de l'autre vous créer une relation au
travail qui est totalement bouleversée
et c'est ça aussi que nous dénonçons
alors sur d'autres sujets qui sont les
sujets internationaux
on a été aussi très surpris de rien voir
vous savez qu'il ya un sujet absolument
fondamental aujourd'hui dans les
institutions européennes qui est en
cours de discussion c'est la directive
sur les travailleurs détachés président
on a parlé plusieurs fois il a eu raison
d'en parler et ce qui s'y passe est très
symptomatique de la démarche des manuels
macron vis-à-vis de nos partenaires
européens
ça demande un peu d'explications et je
vous demande de me suivre
au fond quand macron est élu président
de la république la réforme de la
directive sur les travailleurs détachés
étaient quasiment abouti au parlement
européen et au conseil puisque c'est de
la co décision
les acteurs étaient quasiment arrivés à
un accord qu'il fallait phinney qu'on
allait finaliser
il est élu et nous sommes au mois de
juin et il déclare que rien ne va plus
il veut repousser cette discussion à
l'automne le premier risque de des
pousses de repousser à l'automne c'est
qu'on n'est pas d'accord
à la fin de l'année et quelles sont les
conséquences de ne pas avoir d'accord à
la fin de l'année c'est qu'au 1er
janvier prochain la présidence de
l'union c'est la bulgarie et autant vous
dire que les bulgares eux ils ne rêvent
que d'une autre que d'une chose c'est
que cette directive ne soit pas du tout
révisé donc en voulant montrer qu'il est
le chef en europe avec une sorte de
l'hypertrophie du mois qui commence à
énerver beaucoup de nos partenaires je
peux vous assurer qu'au parlement
européen c'est un vrai sujet eh bien il
prend le risque
de voir cette directive en fait pas
révisé pas révisé pour une deuxième
raison c'est que ne connaissant pas le
sujet il ya que cette explication
et c'est d'autant plus étonnant qu'il a
dans ses conseillers des gens qui sont
de bonne qualité je nous pensons donc
qu'il ne les écoute pas une utilisation
du pouvoir qui est extrêmement isolées
eh bien il dit il faut lier la révision
de cette directive travailleurs détachés
à un règlement qu'on appelle règlement
sécurité sociale c'est à dire en fête
qui traitera la question des indemnités
de sécurité sociale et indemnités
chômage il faut l'ailier c'est tout à
fait ce que veulent les bulgares les
roumains et les polonais parce que c'est
tellement compliqué qu'on n'y arrivera
pas et nous nous avions montré qu'il
fallait pas l'ailier il valait mieux cet
accord que nous avions nous avions
presque plutôt que de repère un an deux
ans trois ans et donc nous accusons
emmanuel macron de quoi par une sorte de
lady d'hypertrophie du moine sorte
d'amateurisme sur ces dossiers complexes
et bien il fait prendre un risque majeur
à l'économie française
nous pouvons avoir une directive
travailleurs détachés rénové qui enfin
servent vraiment l'économie française le
risque c'est que nous n'ayons pas parce
que plus les semaines passent plus les
antilles sont en train de gagner du
terrain en fait il a fait sans le
vouloir réellement sans le vouloir le
jeu des antilles révision de la
directive détaché alors même qu'ils
prétendaient qu'il voulait la réformer
et on voit bien qu'il ya cette
ambivalence complexe chez emmanuel
macron c'est qu'il affirme des choses et
qu en pratique dans les détails dans la
mise en oeuvre
ça ne suit pas ça va même à l'encontre
et on l'a vu sur les simplifications de
la vue sur la csg ou le doigt sur
l'assurance chômage on le voit sur les
questions européennes
un autre élément qui est important pour
les français notamment pour thau su
qu'ils suivent les questions liées à
l'enseignement supérieur et noël macro
ont été dans l'incapacité d'utiliser le
mot sélection alors c'est très étonnant
de la part de quelqu'un qui assume
complètement d'utiliser le mot bordel ce
mot sélection qui n'apparaît ni vulgaire
ni particulièrement populaire mais qui
est un mot qui est courant dans la
langue française n'a pas été prononcée
hier
or nous
meuriot clairement savoir où nous en
sommes sachant que dans sa campagne
électorale
lui qui a dit je ferai tout ce que j'ai
dit avec clairement utilisé ce mot de
sélection ce mot de méritocratie qui
correspond à la social démocratie
donc aujourd'hui nous posons la question
de façon extrêmement clair parce que les
étudiants parce que les professeurs
parce que les enseignants parce que nos
universités nos grandes écoles
notre système notre façon dont nous
projetons par rapport notamment à ski et
le dispositif
même si on peut le décrié de notation et
de shanghai nous avons la nécessité
aujourd'hui de savoir est ce que le
président de la république ou pas va
mettre en place ce dispositif
c'est absolument essentiel question
aussi criante on ne voit malheureusement
au travers bien de remonter qu'on peut
qualifier dans l'ordre de divers mais
également de la vie quotidienne les
violences sexuelles faites aux femmes
dramatique on se rend compte que depuis
quelques années ces questions y compris
en europe y compris en france augmentent
que la place des violences faites aux
femmes au sein des foyers au sein des
couples mais également dans l'espace
public augmente cela évidemment a
dénoncé c'est parfaitement insupportable
dans une société comme la nôtre qui en
mai qui met en étendard évidemment
l'égalité entre les sexes et nous serons
très vigilants et très accompagnant dans
toutes les propositions qui pourront
être faites par la secrétaire d'état par
le gouvernement pour faire en sorte et
bien tout simplement que les jeunes
femmes les jeunes filles mais également
toute personne qui à un moment ou un
autre peut être
harcelés dans le cadre notamment
sexuelles et bien ne puisse pas l'être
sur notre territoire et que les
harceleurs soit effectivement mis dans
le camp des gens qui doivent non
seulement être dénoncés mais qu'ils
doivent être sanctionnés
c'est extrêmement important nous serons
aux côtés du gouvernement dans ce cadre
là donc vous l'avez bien compris à la
discussion est ce que vous allez
soutenir des réformes du gouvernement
quelle est votre position évidemment
nous sommes une opposition moderne
en démocratie il faut pas s'étonner que
l'opposition discute avec la majorité
que nous étions dans la majorité
nous avions la malchance d'avoir une
opposition systématique un peu bébête et
qui n'arrivait pas jamais à se
positionner positivement son vis-à-vis
des réformes que nous faisions même
souvenez vous quand françois hollande a
été élu président de la république
ils ont détricoté en catastrophe d'étape
de mesures que nous avions mise en
oeuvre pour les remettre en oeuvre
quelques années plus tard
donc nous ne sommes pas du tout cette
cette nature là nous sommes des gens
ouverts aux hommes modernes
donc la question n'est pas de savoir si
nous voulons soutenir telle ou telle
réforme
nous soutiendrons les réformes qui sont
bonnes voilà mais nous dénoncerons
celles qui sont mauvaises et quand on
écoute le président hier soir bas on se
dit que finalement il ya assez peu de
choses dans le dur dans le dur pas dans
les déclarations d'intention on veut
tous que les français vivent mieux que
la france est plus d'éclat dans le monde
que nous soyons mieux écouter ça je vais
tout le monde est d'accord mais quand on
rentre dans le dur et bien nous sommes
très inquiets parce que on est souvent
d'une trêve dans une très grande
imprécision et quand on n'est pas dans
la précision n'est dans le choc fiscal
on est donc plus d'impôts plus de
charges pour les uns et des autres et
finalement pour un résultat qui nous
paraît assez assez assez inquiétant avez
vous des questions sur ce sujet sur
d'autres et des élections en autriche on
peut en parler il ya il ya eu les états
généraux de l'alimentation peut en
parler à voix ya ya mille choses à bien
entendu
je vous en prie on suit avec beaucoup
d'intérêt des sommes un peu de lassitude
de l'exclusion dé constructif au sein
des républicains est ce que la question
du maintien de sens commun au sein du
parti fait désormais débat une exclusion
est envisageable
sur ces sujets il ya en fait aucune
ambiguïté l'ambigu n'y a pas d'ambiguïté
nous avons toujours été très clair sur
la ligue politique des républicains
notre famille politique d'ailleurs comme
nous à plomion pas les et républicains
mais l'ump
le sujet était exactement le même il ya
une ligne rouge absolument
infranchissable entre nous et le front
national discute pas avec eux on ne
gouverne pas avec eux on a pas
d'alliances politiques
nous sommes à mille lieues des valeurs
de ce genre là donc c'est valable pour
républicain sénat va pour les élus des
républicains c'est là pour les
responsables des républicains c'est
valable pour les mouvements associés des
républicains sens commun je crois a pris
les positions récemment après les
déclarations malheureuses de son
président qui semble redresser la barre
nous en félicitons on va observer ce qui
se passe mais encore une fois au fond
c'est un non sujet puisque nous nous
avons dit que jamais nous discuterions
avec le front national
donc il faut pas vous nous faire mijoter
cette petite histoire en permanence pour
nous il n'y a pas de débat à sens commun
d'abord les membres de sens commun sont
font partie des républicains
et pour nous ce sujet à une implication
obligatoire c'est pas hypothétique c'est
que sens commun est tenu à la même règle
vis-à-vis du front national que tout
adhérent du front national tout élu tout
adhérent des républicains tout tout tout
tout élu des républicains pas de
changement
ça dépendra de la volonté de sens comme
si sens commun vous discutez avec le
front national ils peuvent mais dans ces
cas là ils seront plus républicain le
choses sont sans ambiguïté je ne crois
pas que ça soit la majorité de la
volonté des membres de sens commun
bonjour pour revenir l'entretien une
d'emmanuel macron vous avez soulevé les
points qui vous satisfait est ce que en
revanche sur le l'annnonce de
l'expulsion immédiate de tous les
clandestins qui commettent un délit est
ce que ça trouve une satisfaction à vos
yeux
pardo merlas jeu je trouve que c'est
l'aboutissement d'une sorte de
dialectique incroyable donc si je
comprends bien les types sont en
situation irrégulière irrégulière donc
par définition il faudrait déjà les
renvoyer mais on va attendre qu'il
commette un délit pour les renvoyer non
nous notre position est tout à fait
différente quand vous êtes en situation
régulière vous devez être expulsé trois
et le fait que le président puisse dire
oui mais ces gens là on va attendre
qu'il commette un délit pour les
expulser nous paraître absolument
incroyable il présente ça comme une
mesure de 2 commence à de sévérité dans
l'application de la loi mais en fait
c'est une mesure de faiblesse dans
l'application de la loi parce que dans
ces cas-là ça signifie quoi être en
situation irrégulière ça signifie qu'à
pas de conséquence sur si on écoute bien
tant qu'on n'a pas commis un délit mais
il se trouve qu être en situation
régulière
c'est un délit et puis est quelque chose
qui nous surprend un petit peu dans la
façon de faire les mêmes accroc en
l'espace être respectueux de la
démocratie c'est aussi écouter son
opposition et l'opposition que nous
représentons le groupe l'est république
à l'assemblée nationale n'y a pas plus
tard que quinze jours apporter un
certain nombre d'amendements justement
proposant un durcissement pour ces
personnes en situation irrégulière qui
commettent des crimes des délits sur
notre sol tous ses amendements ont été
rejetés méthodiquement sans aucune forme
de concertation par le gouvernement de
monsieur almagro
quid est ce à dire que la vérité n'est
vrai que par la majorité et à partir du
moment où des propositions viennent de
l'opposition et bien
être entendu je ne suis pas sûr que ce
soit démocratie moderne en la matière
nous appelons un dialogue renouvelé avec
l'opposition et à la nécessité d'écouter
ce qui est dit quand c'est dans
l'intérêt des français absolument c'est
cette histoire a quand même le mérite de
lever le voile
emmanuel macron se présente comme un
héros de la démocratie moderne
mais vous avez quand même entendu avant
les vacances d'été
cet argument absolument incroyable c'est
que les députés en marche n'ont pas le
droit de co signé des amendements qui
sont déposées par des membres de
l'opposition
personne n'a relevé que si ça c'est pas
une définition de sectarisme je voudrais
m'expliquer en démocratie ce que
signifie le sectarisme
autrement dit l'opposition et sommés
d'être d'accord avec le gouvernement si
nous on nous sommes des secteurs mais
eux qui sont au gouvernement qui ont une
très large majorité sans aucun danger
l'idée même qui puisse soutenir un
amendement déposé par nous c'est un
crime de lèse majesté et je vais vous
dire dans un an et demi et des élections
européennes il va falloir qu'ils
apprennent une chose c'est que au
parlement européen
si vous avez ce type d'attitude qui
consiste à dire moi je ne cautionne
aucun amendement avec personne d'autre
sur la sphère politique bien vous
n'existez pas donc il va falloir
commencer à apprendre ce qu'est la
démocratie et la démocratie est la une
de ses propriétés
c'est le sens du compromis mais nous
nous trouvons qui emmanuel macron il
prétend être moderne et ouvert est en
réalité dans les fêtes il imposa sa
majorité
une attitude extrêmement sectaire et qui
est tout sauf une volonté d'être ouvert
bonjour je voudrais juste vous demander
de refaire un point sur les fameux
constructif dont on parlait est ce
qu'ils sont qui a pu s'exprimer devant
quelle commission quand est ce qu'ils
sont toujours menacés d'expulsion est ce
que vous pouvez un peu récapituler tout
ça parce que c'est vrai qu'on si oui
alors sur les procédures c'est assez
simple nous avons écrit aux membres du
gouvernement qu'ils viennent
initialement notre famille politique
pour leur demander de s'expliquer et qui
nous expliquent ce qu'ils veulent faire
parce que le vrai sujet c'est que on
peut pas être à la fois dans le
gouvernement est dans l'opposition il ya
c'est un peu complexe quand même comme
comme attitude
donc on a écrit à monsieur solaire et
monsieur riester qui ont été entendus
par jean leonetti et jean leonetti va
faire l'audition a déjà eu lieu j'en ai
une qui va faire son rapport au bureau
politique du 24 octobre et avant le 24
octobre monsieur darmanin monsieur
lecornu seront reçus aussi cette fois-ci
par patrick ollier qui va entendre leurs
arguments lors demandé aussi ce qu'ils
imaginent faire est ce qu'ils sont dans
l'opposition la majorité
petite question intéressante en
démocratie et là aussi fera le rapport
aux 24 24 24 octobre le premier ministre
n'a pas répondu mais en même temps lui
c'est clair enfin il est le chef de l'aï
les chefs de la majorité on peut pas
dire qu'il soit le chef de l'opposition
donc pour nous crois tout simplement que
le premier ministre et le premier
ministre
quant à monsieur le maire baïda où il a
eu au moins le courage il faut le saluer
de d'expliquer clairement qui lui
passait à la social démocratie et donc
il a fait un choix
ce choix c'est le sien et nous n'avons
pas de juger nous ne sommes pas emmanuel
macron qui distribue les bons points
selon constitue à droite ou à gauche de
l'échiquier politique
chacun fait ses choix est libre donc
nous nous attendons de savoir ce que
vont nous dire les les constructif du
gouvernement quant à ceux qui sont dans
le groupe constructif à l'assemblée
nationale les neuf en plus de
thierry solère et franck riester on leur
a laissé jusqu'à fin novembre je crois
pour nous dire s'il souhaitait ou pas
intégrer l'opposition c'est-à-dire en
fait le groupe des républicains et
groupe red bull et des républicains pour
lesquels d'ailleurs ils ont eu la
restitue au moment des élections
législatives et il avait pris
l'engagement de siéger dans le groupe
l'est républicain d'ailleurs avant
d'être avant d'être élu donc on va leur
demander s'ils sont d'accord pour
simplement honorer leurs engagements et
leurs paroles parce que la parole nos
politiques sont suspendus